the latest in a Relentless series of
storms battered the California coast on
Tuesday with waves in some places seven
meters tall
the storms have caused widespread
flooding as 90 percent of the state's
population was placed under a flash
flood warning in many places water
saturated hillsides have collapsed in
dangerous mudslides tens of thousands of
people have been evacuated from
communities all over the state we were
watching other people being evacuated
and we just had no idea it was just a
shocker and where we it was just
unbelievable you know seeing the water
come in and then it's just gushing just
like a river
in Sacramento the state capitol utility
Crews worked to restore power high winds
have toppled trees and power lines
leaving more than 200 000 people without
electricity on Tuesday
in Santa Cruz the San Lorenzo River
normally just a trickle of water became
a muddy Brown torrent
beaches were piled high with debris
nearby enormous waves crashed against
Rocky cliffs in one spot tearing away
part of a residential street the storms
have proved costly and deadly people
have been swept away in flood waters and
killed by trees knocked over in high
winds California's emergency agency
estimates the damage May exceed one
billion dollars
and it's not over the fact that we're
not out of the woods we expect these
storms to continue at least through the
18th of this month we expect a minimum
three more of these atmospheric rivers
and different shapes and forms depending
on different parts of the state nearly
half a meter of rain has fallen in some
areas forecasters say downpours will
continue on Wednesday Rob Reynolds Al
Jazeera Santa Cruz California